ciao a tutti benvenuti solite stories
oggi andremo a vedere una challenge che
sta spopolando il resto non suo studio
nuovo se si sia già da un po di tempo in
cui delle ragazze si trasformano in
ragazzi fatica riescono a truccarsi o
comunque non miei capelli e trasformarsi
in ragazzi scendono diventano propri
ragazzi però sembrano dei ragazzi è lì
ho visto un paio è stato di tormento
tutto nuovo non mi sentivo ancora meglio
vediamo un po come sono se volete vedere
altre reazioni del genere lasciate un
bel laiche e fatemi sapere se vi piace
questa challenge si chiama la boj
challans in cui ragazze interessano i
ragazzi sarebbe bello vedere anche il
contrario ragazzi che si trasformano il
re che questo giusto ma lo facciamo mai
non io penso mi aiuta perché allora
lasciate un bel haj che poi si sta bene
se vi piace questa chavez iniziamo
subito ok vediamo un po
[Musica]
wow non molla sembra davvero un ragazzo
ha quindi pratica mettono la cosa
davanti fanno l'effetto col cappuccio
però non si fanno vedere bene all'inizio
bisognerebbe vederle meglio prima della
trasformazione ma non ci credeva neanche
lei saresti curata lo speaker è rimasta
scioccata che fino a suffragare il succo
enorme
allora questa l'abbiamo vista già un po
meglio quindi presto sono praticamente
tutti la stessa tecnica si può provare
anch'io allora fatemi sapere se volete
che si provi anch'io se si vede vera una
ragazza un po no vediamo questo se
riesce bene
ma cosa ma dove sarà fisica quelli
biondi ha cambiato penso che erano come
stiamo facendo
la ricrescita perché è stato un posto
davvero assurdo propria festa sempre la
stessa è la tecnica mini col cappuccio
questi viene ancora che una ragazza che
il ragazzo rimane scioccato dio mio dio
ragazzi wow però si vede che una ragazza
già vediamo queste sono le ragazze per
amore bene in faccia ad esempio bene
faremo le bene ok vediamo da non è
giusto così stanno imbrogliando vediamo
si diventa biondo o moro
forse abbiamo giorno moro
[Musica]
tanta tanta buche ciuffo allora questa
curiosa perché lei è anche truccata
quindi è un po più complicato vediamo
prepara anche a procurarsi aveva fatto
le sopracciglia più grandi no voglio
fare anch'io troppo divertente è
sembrata fare un ragazzo qua inquietante
ma non si è vista prima
[Musica]
così è così si vedeva un po perché
sapevo non avesse benissimo è cambiato
pelle ricevere un po sì sempre molto
femminile e mattonelle perché in realtà
va così così
questa difficile prova tanta tanta tanta
che
che cosa senza mettere il piercing e
scapuzzi ho improvvisato però funzionato
[Musica]
ha fatto bene quest'anno tutti la stessa
tecnica insieme ragazzo vediamo in
questo effetto muccino sono i primi
erano carichi ma allora la società anche
se volete che problemi che questa spalle
se questo video prudentissimi all'aics
proverò anch'io se curiosi di vedere
sono curioso del maschio si è spaventata
voilà hoc e trasformazione ieri la costa
dove si può stare
sì sembrata fare un ragazzo
poi al contrario lo hanno fatto perché
non aveva però è una ragazza ma c'è il
fratello dico io wow
può essere anche tra casa ma non ho
capito
era un ragazzo ora diventerà una ragazza
a voi avete capito no questa non è una
persona dai l'avete vista ebbene sì
memorizzate no ragazzo mi somiglia al
fratello che anzo trono e vale se guardi
le mans secondo me lei se lo aveva più
pronunciata
così così la trasformazione
questo è fatta al contrario a durban
tedesco il makeup arancione ieri con i
capelli lunghissimi si fa più complicato
ma anche questo al contrario è un
ragazzo davvero
[Musica]
non ha senso lato anche 3 o alcuni
incredibile come riescono a trasformarsi
abbastanza
[Musica]
si vedono sempre che una ragazza ho
fatto bene o no è cambiata tantissimo
siamo al quarto sembra veramente un
ragazzo nascono ma questa esce bene
vediamo
no non tanto
il sito beh sembrava un ragazzo
veramente è sparita nel frattempo più
nessuno a questa marca puccio vero ma
fate come farà
[Musica]
incredibile a questa sta facendo la
trasformazione completa jesi
[Musica]
si vede che la ragazza
le acconciature abbiamo ora sono tutte
simili alla justin bieber trovano perché
voluto legare i capelli lunghi sopra
cappellino
anche questo è fatto al contrario così
sembrava un ragazzo l'ha fatto bene più
belle queste affrontare questa
fondamentale si di ebi capelli tra
l'altro ma di nuovo lo stesso no non
credo
sì perché
così bene dai per questo ora secondo te
a me riuscire bene
wow
no no posso provare tipo non il
cappuccio adesso
ma con gli effetti non si vede come
sembra una parrucca decima ragazzo
moviole mi dice che così incredibile
rosa si sta
o si terrà sarebbe bello andare a scuola
di buongiorno così trasformati
fondamento chiamato dopo un secondo
vediamo un curioso testa no non tanto
male dai sacco di pranzo questo al
contrario lo stesso i valori ci ha visto
questo non mi ricordo
no perché si muove anche il lo sfondo
dietro nostra
no così il video davvero di 0 7 presenta
e brava forse un effetto e mafia
non si è visto infatti nel male
immaginasse una ragazza fa in giro
sempre così e poi le ragazze si
innamorano di lui lei e poi scoprono le
rende una ragazza foto vero
no scusate sentito forse il nostro
visivo che canta ogni tanto ha fatto
bene
caspita basterà incredibile è stata
rapida questa trasformazione oca piccola
questa bimba si sta
[Musica]
chi e quanti capelli che a questa
ragazza
[Musica]
la barba
ma dove sono i capelli cosa è successo
basti dire tagliati fatto degli effetti
però
[Musica]
capelli gli occhi
no per me non sembra un ragazzo anche
questa foto al contrario forse pensi
allora abbiamo deciso di non farvi
aspettare troppo e proviamo questa
chance per evitare si trasformerà da
donna e io proverò da uovo però insomma
la facciamo un po il bronzata diciamolo
non c'è giu stiamo bene non ci
trucchiamo anzi non la facciamo però gli
elaborata e sarà una prova
se volete la possono più elaborata sono
sarebbe troppo lungo
aspetta queste baretti ne è sempre
voluto essere bionda alta che sono
biondi seta qua davanti
questo perché più corta ma fate
[Musica]
[Applauso]
[Risate]
[Musica]
sono tutti sparati cappelli qua allora
cos'è i piatti sono bellissime questo
diciamo così mi sono trasformato il
ragazzo e la trasformazione era questa
allora i piatti sempre tipo un boxer uno
che fa box anni 80
anzi no un camionista degli anni 80 che
sono tutti così e biondi al bar ma per
una ragazza cameri ma io sono un
camionista dentro pranzo odiati di
profilo c'è questa frangia lunghissima
tipo o meglio al contrario nome allora
ti piazzi insomma bellissima provo io
vedrei i capelli corti ma pubblicato la
seconda per il giro per citare un
pochettino roba sto facendo cosi ti dico
si aspetta
[Musica]
come un ragazzo tipo che si fa così
allora vi presentiamo alito evitava nel
panorama della sala di piazza v il
ragazzo era gatti trasformazioni
fantastiche gli lasciamo come come stai
oggi per mettere nissimo vedermi così
con i capelli cortissimi però non penso
di sembrare un ragazzo voi cosa ne dite
pontificia bene se secondo voi io sembro
un ragazzo e se secondo voi è vitale
sembra una ragazza davanti se i nostri
come sempre più una ragazza che il
ragazzo è stato reso correzione delle
altre trasformazioni da parte nostra
e se vi piace questa nostra
trasformazione magari ci riproviamo in
cui io ti trucco
la ragazza bene come si è mai ragazzi
cioè non va
magari mi sento un po il supporto di
esperti mi faccio la barba e mi
trasforma il ragazzo che cosa ne pensate
si sapeva che io sto benissimo con
questa criniera dalle ora mi sembra che
ti piazzano questi capelli e dalle ore
però sembra un cane di un barboncino 47
cliccare per vedere le nostre altre
challenge i nostri video divertenti e
sete eccetera kiki hakansson la sorpresa
temi buongiorno digital